for many streamers
twitch isn't a hobby it's their
livelihood
so it can be a really big deal when
their accounts get suspended
now most of the time the reasons for the
suspension can be
pretty mundane but sometimes they can be
weird shocking or
just plain ridiculous so with that said
here are the top 10 banned streamers
starting off at number 10 we have the
chaotic goodness that is
xqc now if we're being honest we'd be
able to make an
entire top 10 list out of xqc's twitch
bands alone
so it's tough figuring out where to even
start here
xqc was recently banned for stream
sniping at twitch rivals
and was previously banned for showing a
porn video which had apparently been
edited to be
safe for work in the video they watched
there's a frame that isn't fully covered
and there's a piece there's a piece of
dick that shows up at some point
and i'm getting banned for three days
for it bans due to sexually explicit
content continued
when he got hit with a banhammer for
playing a game on stream
where a female character would strip
whenever he beat her
at connect four and who can forget the
time he accidentally opened a video
sent by a viewer of two gorillas getting
it on
much love welcome to the the jungle
excuse me
[Music]
next up at number nine we have
everyone's favorite political bro hassan
abi
what a liar dude what a
weasley little liar dude hassan has
become
wildly popular for his biting commentary
on political hot potatoes
but back in 2019 he seemed to bite off
more than he could chew he was suspended
from twitch for something he said
while reacting to us congressman dan
crenshaw's defense
of america's many military bases around
the world
this is so insane
america deserve 9 11 dude get i'm saying
it
we're there to partner with them we want
to know what's happening
we totally brought it on ourselves dude
holy [ __ ]
we did we did in a video game whatever
hypothetically politically
we did man we did after the
shitstorm that followed twitch suspended
hassan for
seven days he took to twitter to clarify
his position
stating that he doesn't support
terrorism but was criticizing the
american government
for supporting it while admitting that
he used imprecise
language that was turned against him
ice poseidon takes that number 8 spot
with some serious swatting
streamers have to be careful with any
info they give out
especially irl streamers like ice
poseidon and
especially if they're streaming from an
airport
i don't know dude i might be on terminal
five i don't know what i don't know
where i am i'm just on 53a as my that's
my gate
and i'm not sure telling you guys that
is a good idea but i what can you
possibly do right
that's right we're talking about the
time when one of his viewers
called in a bomb threat on ice police
searching an american airlines plane
at sky harbor police say an anonymous
threat was called in
that threat wound up being not credible
several passengers who were
on the plane tell me that the man who
was removed was taking a video of
himself
at the gate in l.a before the plane took
off
twitch permanently suspended ice
poseidon for broadcasting the flight's
details
which forced him to stream on mixer for
the duration of his
ban now ice did release an open letter
to twitch asking for a second chance
but the band still holds to this day my
point is
i've learned a lot in the past couple of
years and i've been a streamer for
almost five years now
and i'm please asking twitch to just
give me a second chance
moving on to number seven we have
alinity wardrobe malfunctions happen
they happen in real life they happen on
tv and yes they can also happen on
twitch
people expected a band for nudity to
follow
from twitch but when it never came the
community was
up in arms about the perceived double
standards
and they were also mad that elinity
wasn't banned for forcing her pets to
drink
alcohol on stream here's where it gets
really strange though
while twitch was silent alinetti
actually gave herself
a three-day suspension later that day
twitch eventually banned her for 24
hours
elinity fought twitch over that but not
to get the band removed
but to get it extended as she felt it
wasn't long enough
i'm sure twitch was just as confused as
the rest of us
stumbling his way into number six now we
have mango
the smash star got hit with a ban in
january 2019
after getting way too drunk and
seemingly passing out
on stream
now while you or i might find that kind
of funny twitch doesn't have much time
for these sorts of drunken antics
they suspended mango for seven days for
dangerous consumption of drugs or
alcohol but
he wanted to set the record straight and
said that he didn't pass out on stream
but just
jokingly fell over because he wanted to
take a break
now i'm no pro streamer but i can think
of at least 10
ways to end a stream that doesn't
involve my face
hitting the floor i guess i kind of had
it coming honestly
i i can't even i can't even try and
defend myself i i
i had it coming next up at number
five we have phantom lord
the skin gambling controversies of 2016
saw a number of big content creators
exposed for allegedly
shady cs go gambling practices
see some streamers who were gambling
with cs go skins on stream
were allegedly financially involved in
the sites they were gambling on
valve eventually cracked down on the
problem and ruled it against their terms
of service which in turn meant that it
was also against twitch's terms of
service
and phantom lord was found to be
breaking those terms of service when he
streamed himself on a site called
cs go shuffle allegedly rigging the
results in his
favor and not disclosing his involvement
with the site
now it's time no come back
[Applause]
of course twitch permanently suspended
phantom lord for that but the story
doesn't end there
after going under the radar for over a
year and a half
phantom lord returned to announce he was
suing twitch for the ban
claiming he was not given a written
explanation for it and was even given
their permission to stream that content
for 30 minutes a day
i assure you that i am considering all
of my legal options
and am looking forward to asserting my
rights to the fullest extent
of the law after a
lengthy legal process the trial is
finally set to take place in march
2021 over four years since this whole
thing started
we're going back to 2013 for our number
four entry which comes courtesy of
zillion op
he was a streamer known in part for
being in a wheelchair which is why it
was all the more shocking to his viewers
when this happened maybe
like at the end of the expansion when
it's easily out geared
oh my god we took our dog um
he had previously raised thousands of
dollars on stream for items such as an
electric wheelchair
so you can imagine just how outraged his
viewers were when he just got up and
walked away from his computer
despite claiming that physical therapy
had allowed him
some limited mobility a twitch ban
followed the incident
zillionopy disappeared and was only seen
in failed compilations until 2020
when he returned to clear his name the
entire story is blown into a proportion
that's not entirely true
my whole stream knew that i was going
through physical therapy
no one knew the extent of my recovery i
was in a wheelchair for two years i was
in a car accident
zillion op now streams on youtube under
the name
bluish and hopes to put this whole
wheelchair controversy
firmly in his past
moving on to number three we have casey
trump by now i think it's fair to say
that kovid is no
joke early on in the pandemic casey tron
was asked a question on stream
and a lot of people didn't appreciate
her answer if he had the coronavirus
would you kiss him
yes and we would leave quarantine and we
would try to spread it as much as paul
is
as much as possible because the world
would be a better place without old and
poor people oh my god what the [ __ ]
yeah she actually said that a lot of
people were outraged by this tasteless
comment and twitch slapped casey with an
indefinite ban for hateful conduct
against a group of people
it seems like twitch had more of a
problem with the joke being aimed at
poor and
old people although i'm sure joking
about intentionally spreading the virus
didn't go down too well with them either
moving on now we're getting trigger
happy at number two with saw carl
[ __ ] say i ain't got money say i ain't
got money
god damn that was the moment that saw
carl's twitch career
went out with a bang playing with guns
is dumb
playing with guns while drunk is even
dumber and firing one of them off on
stream like that is one of the fastest
ways to get your channel
shut down i'm an idiot you know it's
just that simple
i am so unbelievably stupid and
i could have possibly ruined my life i
could have
hurt somebody i could have hurt myself i
could have hurt one of my animals and
that's unforgivable
but i just don't know what i'm gonna do
and finally at number one we have the
ongoing mystery
of dr disrespect's twitch ban on june
16th 2020 the docs fans went to his
twitch channel to find that it had been
permanently suspended it was a shock
nobody knew why this had happened i
appreciate everyone watching today it's
in the backyard who is going to be
looking forward to it
we'll get through this champions club
that's i know it's a tough that's
because
life's weird right now i in an
unprecedented move twitch even
refunded his subs as with most bands
people looked to the streamer for
answers but the doc tweeted out saying
that
even he had no idea why twitch had
banned him
he began streaming on youtube and it
didn't take long for him to address the
situation
although his answers remained as vague
as ever and then have that taken away
from you
and to not know why and to not know
anything about it
not to be told nothing boom taken
grabbed everything we built all the eggs
in one bucket
boom taken away well those are some of
our most
memorable bands have you guys got any
other ones that you can think of
make sure you subscribe to the score
esports if you haven't done so already
thanks for watching guys and i'll see
you all in the next one
if you were a streamer like how or how
would you be banned if you got a twitch
band like what would
be the most likely like way that you got
banned well like when they play games
like just swear a lot i'll be like
you know i'll be like oh i'm gonna go
you know i'm gonna go
get this guy or like oh like i just did
this
it's just like constant and i'm just
like does twitch have like a counter
like how many
shits can you say in like a five minute
period because that would probably be it
to be honest